Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Fußball der Männer und sprechen heute über die Premier League, die Serie A, die Liga äh und La Liga, das tun wir mit Nils Kahn, Uli Hebel, Mario Rieker und Alexi Menüch jetzt hier im RASFUNK. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und hallo und herzlich willkommen an eine fast ebenso große Runde hier. Guten Morgen, ihr vier. Ihr sagt es einfach einmal gesammelt, guten Morgen. Da sparen wir gleich mal Zeit an. Guten Morgen. Ganz fantastisch. Ich liebe diese morgendlichen Zusammenknöpfe. Kurz Hand hoch, wer hat gestern Abend noch arbeiten müssen? Bei Mario weiß ich es, bei Neil weiß ich alle. Uli, du nicht?
Ja, faszinierend. Okay, aber es baut uns gleich die Brücke zu deinem Ansang, Hero. Denn wir bleiben im Bereich der trainer.
Ja, das ist wieder der Mokler, den ich hier einmal drin habe vor Ligatour. So kann ich dir schön Fulham unterjubeln. Naja, aber im Ernst ist wirklich, glaube ich, auch wieder die Definition eines Ansangheroes, Marco Silva, trainer von Fulham, weil sie sehr gut gestartet sind mit einem Programm, zugegebenermaßen, das machbar ist für Fulham. So hätten sie es auch ungefähr machen müssen, um potenziell die Möglichkeit, sich zu erhalten, einstellig zu werden, aber warum nenne ich Silva? Weil in dem Verein stimmt nicht immer alles. Man ist nicht so ganz glücklich mit, wie die Fans behandelt werden. Es wird immer teurer. Man ist nicht so ganz glücklich mit teilweise späten Transferentscheidungen. Einerseits Abgänge von Top-Top-Spielern. Diesmal ist João Paulinho zwar relativ früh gegangen, aber im Jahr davor spät. Der Director der Fußball kümmert sich ganz viel um Wrestling und nicht so viel um Fußball, wie er sollte und so weiter und so weiter. Und Markus Silva ist aber derjenige, der es immer wieder hinbringt, eine neue Mannschaft zu formen. Er hat ganz klammheimlich wahrscheinlich das physischste Team der Liga aufgebaut. Es ist erstaunlich, wie viel Athletik, wie viel Wucht, wie viel einfach grundsätzlich Präsenz, aber auch Schnelligkeit, Dynamik in dem Kader ist. Und ist jemand, den, glaube ich, den verehren sie inzwischen im Graven Cottage, weil er eben ein Team geschaffen hat, das nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben wird. Niemals. Im Gegenteil, vielleicht sogar, wenn sie Glück haben, irgendwann mal zu den– das sind ja eigentlich keine Big Six mehr, wir sind ja eher schon jetzt Top 8 oder so, wenn man Newcastle und Villa noch mit reinzählen will. Und ich glaube, Essenwehr muss man inzwischen da jetzt mit reinnehmen. Und vielleicht kann Fulham sogar zumindest einmal aufschließen dazu. Auch im Cup zuletzt einen ordentlichen Run gehabt, nah dran gewesen, mal im Halbfinale zumindest gestanden. Ein sehr Storatyp. Er wurde ja mal aus Miniu Mourinho gelabelt. Er hat mal einen Job in Portugal verloren, weil er sich geweigert hat, zum Bankett einen Anzug anzuziehen. Sondern wollte im trainingsanzug kommen. Also da wird irgendwas anderes gewesen sein. Aber so ist die offizielle Verlautbarung gewesen, dass er sich nicht an den Kontakt gehalten hat. Und jetzt ist er beim 4. Premier League Club. Und bei dem scheint es jetzt wirklich hundertprozentig hinzuhauen.
Stark. Und ich sehe schon die Anzang Hero Kategorie. Die ist offenbar prädestiniert für trainer, weil die nicht so oft besungen werden. Denn auch Mario hat uns einen trainer mitgebracht. Wer ist es geworden?
Ja, genau. Ich habe gedacht, ich schließe mich da direkt an. Es ist Marco Baroni. Letzte saison hat er das fast Unmögliche möglich gemacht und Hellas in der Serie A gehalten. Auch deswegen ist er auf den Radar von größeren Clubs gekommen. Er hat bei Lazio übernommen. Da war ich super skeptisch. Man muss sagen, bei Lazio ist ein Riesenumbruch. Sergej Mlinković-Savić ist dem Ruf des Gelbes gefolgt. In die Emirate, Ciro Immobile ist nach Zubeşiktaş gegangen. Auch ein Zocker wie Luis Alberto hat nicht mehr da, die immer super wichtig waren. Also alles neu. Marco Boroni hat jetzt vier seiner ersten sieben Spiele gewonnen. Auch einer in der Europa League war dabei, ein ziemlich überzeugender. Wie er das geschafft hat und wie er es dann geschafft hat, in dem Zuge auch noch so Spieler wie Gwendou Zid zum absoluten Leistungsträger zu etablieren, hat mich schon auf jeden Fall beeindruckt, weil der auch immer einer war, der auf dem schmalen Grad zwischen– also Genie würde ich es dann noch nicht in den Mund nehmen wollen, aber auch einer, der schon zeigt, dass er Fußball spielen kann, aber auch immer wieder Spiele und Aussetzer hatte, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das reicht eigentlich nicht für weiter oben. Und jetzt hält er da im Mittelfeld das Ding beisammen. Ein Zarcani hat die Kapitänsbinde übernommen, den man auch aus der italienischen Nationalmannschaft kennt. Also da ist nicht alles nur irgendwie B-Ware, was rumläuft an Spielern, aber das ist trotzdem angesichts der Fluktuation auch auf vor allem wichtigen Positionen, was Mannschafts-Chirurgie angeht, bemerkenswert, wie Baroni so zumindest jetzt den saisonstart für Lazio gestaltet hat. Das hätte ich ihnen auf jeden Fall nicht zugetraut, sondern ich glaube, ich habe sie bei uns in der saisonvorschau sogar auf einen fast zweistelligen Tabellenrang getippt. Deswegen nutze ich die Kategorie auch hier, sozusagen, um schon mal ein bisschen Abhitte zu leisten bei Lazio und Marco Baroni.
Das wird das neue Ding, der Ablasshandel des Rasenfunks. Hier könnt ihr euch freisprechen von euren rhetorischen Sünden der Vergangenheit. Da bin ich dann zuerst mein eigener Kunde, ehrlicherweise muss man dazu sagen. Und wir bleiben bei den Tränen, denn auch du, Nils, möchtest uns über jemanden was erzählen, der es auch geschafft hat, mit seinem Team tatsächlich aktuell in den Top 6 zu stehen.
Genau. Ich mache das trainer-quintet komplett. Und da geht es um einen trainer, der wird bei seinem neuen Verein bestimmt schon ein bisschen besungen, aber noch nicht unbedingt in der Öffentlichkeit. Wenn man sich die La-Liga-Tabelle anschaut, fällt als erstes bestimmt auch der Tabell in Sechste auf. Das ist der Real Club Deportivo Mallorca. Und dort ist Jacubo Arasate. Der war die letzten sechs Jahre durchaus sehr erfolgreich bei Ossasuna, hat da ganz gut mit Nachwuchs gearbeitet, kam ins Pokalfinale und so weiter. Ist dann aber freiwillig gegangen, wollte nicht mehr verlängern. Um sich jetzt einer gefühlt noch größeren Herausforderung Mallorca, wo du vielleicht auch ein bisschen überschaubares Spielmaterial hast, die ich ganz so viel Nachwuchs hast, da hat er sich angeschlossen dem Club. Und aktuell gab es, glaube ich, zuletzt drei Siege in Folge. Haben auch zuvor schon gegen Real Madrid ein 1 zu 1 zu Hause geholt, wie schon oft ein Kader, der gar nicht so stark verändert wurde. Also er hat jetzt keinen von Ossasuna mitgenommen. Von VfL Bochum kam natürlich Arzano, aber auch der ist mehr so Ergänzungsspieler. Und Mallorca hat an sich begrenzte, überschaubare spielerische Mittel. Da ist auch natürlich viel defensive Disziplin, viele lange Bälle. Murici vorne ist ein absoluter Knipser. Und trotzdem holen sie irgendwie aus gefühlt wenig sehr viel raus, sind schwer zu bespielen, sehr diszipliniert. Dani Rodriguez spielt eine gute saison natürlich. Und da führt Arasate die Arbeit von seinem Vorgänger Javi Aguirre. Der hatte Mallorca jetzt auch ins Pokalfinale geführt. Führt er ganz gut fort. Und ja, irgendwie sind sie da selbst in gewissen Statistiken auch so im Mittelfeld hinsichtlich. Abschlüsse, sogar ein bisschen Ballbesitzer. Es ist jetzt nicht nur mauern und eklig sein, aber das können sie schon auch. Und wie gesagt, durchaus effizient und holen da raus, was geht. Und deswegen ist Platz 6 aktuell gar nicht mal unverdient.
Durchaus effizient bei acht geschossenen Toren und sechs kassierten Toren sind 14 Punkte. Da hat man die richtige Verteilung der Tore und Gegentore auf jeden Fall gewählt. Sehr schön haben wir Mallorca auch mal wieder hier untergebracht in der Ligatur. Dann haben wir noch unsere Geschichte der Woche. Wir beginnen wieder in der Ligue 1. Alexi, was hast du uns mitgebracht?
Ja, der tiefe Abstieg oder Fall von Gérard-Andre Bordeaux war der traditionsreichste Verein der Frankreichs in der Geschichte. Jetzt steht man in der fünften Liga, vergleichbar mit der Asien-Club Straßburg vor knapp zehn Jahren. Nur Straßburg ist hier letztes Jahr aufgestiegen. Es steht jetzt solid in der ersten Liga. Ob es Gérard-Andre schafft, wage ich zu bezweifeln, weil da viel zu viel Unruhe herrscht. Vor allem das größte Gift dieses Abstiegs heißt Gérard Lopez, ein luxemburgischer Unternehmer, der schon in den OSC Lille vor fünf, sechs Jahren in die Ruine geführt hat. Und jetzt macht er das Gleiche mit Gérard-Bordeaux. Natürlich traurig, weil solche Namen brauchst du in der Ligue 1. Man war schon im Omburgal-Finale, früher hatte man herausragende Spieler wie Sarazou, Degary, aber vor allem sind sie dann. Und jetzt spielt man vor 200 Zuschauern im Durchschnitt. Man hat World Cup-Grode von Amir.
Ist da alle Fans weggebrochen? Können die nicht mehr in ihrem Stadion spielen? Oder 200 Zuschauer?
Die dürfen momentan nicht in ihrem Stadion spielen, weil ein Verein, der in der fünften Liga spielt, darf nicht in seinem Stadion spielen. In Frankreich sind fast keine Tribüne da sogar. Und auch 200 natürlich auswärts, darunter 150 aus Bordeaux. Also wie gesagt, sehr, sehr traurig. Ich weiß nicht, wie es da weitergeht. Aber die haben auch die Liga gestartet mit zwei Spieltagen später, sodass die die ersten beiden Spiele auf dem grünen Teppich verloren haben und bisher noch keinen einzigen Sieg auf dem Konto haben. Und so wird es auch schwer, sofort aufzusteigen am Ende der saison. Auch wenn sich da ehemalige Spieler angemeldet haben und der Kader mehr als 30 Spieler momentan zusammenfasst.
Kannst du das nochmal kurz erklären, warum Teams nicht in ihrem eigenen Stadion spielen, in der fünften Liga?
Das ist, weil die Liga nicht mehr Profi ist. Also du hast einen Amateur-Status. Und wenn es so ist, darfst du nicht in einer so modernen Arena spielen, wie Bordeaux der Nord-Atlantik. Das ist halt eine komische Regel, aber das steht in den Status des fantastischen Liga-Verbandes.
Der französische Fußballer, er schafft es immer wieder, mich aufs Neue zu faszinieren. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Ich meine, also eigentlich müsste man da zu einem Tribüngespräch machen, zu diesem Downfall, und eigentlich müsste man zu der Person Gerard Lopez ein Tribüngespräch machen. Das ist ja Wahnsinn, wie man als Totengräber gleich mehrere Vereine von einem zum nächsten ziehen kann und einfach nur, weil man viel Geld mitbringt, kommt aus dem Private-Equity-Bereich, werden da ihm die Tore aufgemacht, aber Wahnsinn. Okay. Es ist wirklich heftig. Und ich meine, wenn wir dann noch TV-Vertrag, 2. Liga zum Beispiel noch mit angucken, da könnte man noch drüber sprechen, Montagsspiele und so weiter und so fort. Also die Liga, bzw. dieses Gesamtkonstrukt bewirbt sich schon sehr, sehr lange dafür, dass ich da irgendwann mal mit mehr Zeit draufschaue. Aber schön, dass Bordeaux wenigstens hier noch kurz stattgefunden hat. Dieser Downfall ist wirklich schlimm. Ja, jetzt weiß ich auch nicht, wie die Überleitung sein kann. Jetzt zur nächsten Geschichte der Preparate League. Vor allem, weil ich nicht weiß, welche Geschichte es ist.
Ich weiß es bis jetzt auch noch nicht ganz genau, welche ich nehme. Ich habe erst überlegt, es wird schon ein bisschen rauer zwischen Arsenal und City, aber es ist alles langweilig. Es ist so viel Day-to-Day, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ich nehme mal was anderes, weil es mich total verwundert hat und weil ich es aber überragend finde. Ich mache mal ein kurzes Schlenker zum US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf im November. Klar. Ja, logisch.
Fußball ist unpolitisch, Uli. Ich möchte es dir nur noch mal sagen.
Ja, genau. Das ist auch Most Random, einer der komischsten Crossovers, die ich je gesehen habe. Ich weiß auch gar nicht genau, wie Sie darauf gekommen sind. Auf der einen Seite ist es so genial. Es gibt ein TikTok-Video von Kamala Harris. Hast du es schon gesehen? Ich fand das überragend. Es gibt einen Kommentar von Alan Schirra live für die BBC während des F-Media-Schießens Englands gegen die Schweiz bei der Europameisterschaft. Da wird er nach Druck gefragt. Er sagt, was für Druck, Druck ist was für Reifen. Genau diese Phrase haben sie eingebaut, über ein paar Bilder gelegt von Trump und seinem designierten Vize. Das ist einfach nur eine Geschichte, die bringt jetzt keinen weiter. Aber ich finde das weltklasse. Das ist so ein Schirr-Thing, der als Experte einfach, ehrlich, niemanden weiterbringt. Das war das Beste, was er je gesagt hat. Das fand ich auch wirklich irgendwie witzig, wie er es so rübergebracht hat in seiner Art und Weise. Und dass das jetzt US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf landet, finde ich irgendwie stark. Deswegen war ich sonst nirgends wohin verwenden kann.
Das war super.
Sehr, sehr gut. Sie hätte es nur toppen können, wenn sie da Oli Kahn drüber gelegt hätte. Vielleicht hat er auch noch was zu Druck gesagt. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Kann ich mir schwer vorstellen. Ja, das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass wir...
Ich? Wo war ich unsicher?
Okay, sehr schön. Kamala Harris. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass wir die hier auch noch unterbringen. Mario, wen hast du dabei?
Ich habe im weitesten Sinne Claudio, genannt, Boccia, Gallimberti dabei. Und da tauchen wir sozusagen jetzt ab in einen Filmtipp. Wir hatten vorhin ja schon einmal die Ultras angesprochen. Es kommt jetzt demnächst, am 10.10. ist Deutschland-Premiere in Frankfurt, eine Dokumentation über einen in Italien sehr bekannten Atalanta-Ultra in die Kinos. Aguabia di Una Fede, kann man übersetzen so ein bisschen mit Wächter eines Glaubens. Eine sehr streitbare Person auf jeden Fall. Der hat auch nicht alles richtig gemacht in seinem Leben. Aber auch sehr viel Gutes bewirkt. Wir können uns vielleicht auch zurückerinnern an die Covid-Zeit in Bergamo. Die Ultras haben die Stadt am Leben gehalten. Der hat viel gemacht. Gegen den sind viele Prozesse geführt worden, auch in Italien. Inzwischen ist er ein Steuermann auf einem Fischerboot. Ich habe Teile davon schon gesehen, noch nicht alles. Deswegen ist es natürlich auch ein Filmtipp, den ich nicht komplett belegen kann. Aber ich glaube, es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, sich das anzugucken. Der kommt dann auch nach München. Sogar mal mit Produzent und Regisseur sind auch da. Danach kommt er auch einfach so in die Kinos. Wahrscheinlich ist nicht immer in einem Cinemax, Mathezer etc., aber man wird es bestimmt in Programmkinos finden. Eine Sache in der Filmankündigung, die ich irgendwie ganz passend fand, der Regisseur Zambelli beschreibt auch den Prozess, durch den der Fußball von einem Sport für alle zum globalen Geschäft wurde, bis die Tribünen durch die Covid-Pandemie schließlich leer blieben. Und alles halt aufgehängt an Claudio Boccia Gallimberti aus Bergamo, der da lange Zeit der Anführer der Curva Nord war, bis er dann auch lange Jahre nicht im Stadion sein durfte und ins Exil gegangen ist. Ich glaube, alle, die sich ein bisschen für ihre Fankultur und italienische Fankultur interessieren, ist das auf jeden Fall eine Pflichtveranstaltung.
Aber wirklich, wird unter anderem gezeigt in Frankfurt, in München, in Düsseldorf, in Gelsenkirchen, Leipzig, Hamburg, Magdeburg und Berlin. Ich werde einen Link in die Show notes packen und wir gucken mal, ob wir vielleicht so einen Ligatour mitwirkenden Treffen da rund um die Münchentermine hinbekommen. Da es Männer-Länderspiel kommen, können wir darauf verzichten auf die Premiere von Jannis Plasvik im Tor von Deutschland. Und den Dreierpack von Tim Kleindienst, den sehen wir ja dann in den Highlights. Was sehen wir, wenn wir nach La Liga noch ein letztes Mal blicken, Nies?
Das ist jetzt keine große, witzige Geschichte. Es ist eher eine Sache, was beim FC Barcelona jetzt passiert ist, wo jemand aus dem Ruhestand geholt wurde. Das, was man sich bei Ray Madrid vielleicht auch wünschen würde, so, hey Toni, hast du an den Wochenenden wirklich so viel zu tun? Magst du dich nochmal die Schuhe schüren? Nein, bei Barca, Testegen habt ihr natürlich alle mitbekommen. Paar Teller sehen Riss quasi saison aus. Und Iñaki Peña, Ersatz Torwart, hat man nicht zugetraut, dass er jetzt über die saison hinweg da die Nummer eins ist. Deswegen hat man geschaut, so, wen man holen kann. Es gibt ja dann die Regel, vertragslose oder freie Torhüter darf man dann noch verpflichten. Da gab es ein paar Kandidaten, Loris Karius hat es nicht geschafft. Aber es ist die Wahl gefallen, jetzt auch offiziell auf Wojciech Czesny. Dessen Vertrag bei Juve war ausgelaufen und dann hat er sich hier und da noch so ein bisschen fit gehalten und gehofft, vielleicht kriegt er noch was. Aber eigentlich hat er dann auch schon gesagt, dass er dann eigentlich schon wieder abgeschlossen hatte, dann sein Karriereende bekannt gegeben hat. Und ja, aber dann irgendwie kam die Verletzung. Lewandowski hat dann schnell das Handy gezückt und seinen Ex-Kollegen von der Nationalmannschaft angerufen. Und ja, jetzt ist er auf einmal da. Bin gespannt, wie fit er ist, weil er ist ja auch bekannt so ein bisschen als Lebe-Mann, der auch gerne mal das Leben genießt, wie er da jetzt von der Fitness da ist. Aber es gab natürlich Medizin-Check und alles. Also, Czesny ist zurück, das ist so die Geschichte, dass er da jetzt der Testigen-Ersatz ist. Man weiß natürlich noch nicht, wie fit er ist. Und ich glaube, letztes Jahr bei Juve war er ja noch voll gesetzt, kam auf über 30 Spiele. Da kann vielleicht auch Mario noch was sagen, ob er da auf jeden Fall noch ein guter ist, wovon ich mal ausgehe. Er ist ja jetzt noch keine 40 oder so, 35, glaube ich, 34, ja.
Ja, also mich hat voll gefreut, dass ich das gelesen habe, weil ich finde, dass es eigentlich irgendwie ein, zwei Jahre zu früh war noch, dass er die Fußballschuhe an den Nagel gehängt hat. Aber bei Juve hat man sich halt entschlossen, irgendwie da den nächsten Schritt zu gehen und die Gregorio zu holen. jaisnijsa, habe ich das mitbekommen, glaube ich, er so Saudi- oder so League Cater machen können, aber das wollte er halt auch nicht, auch wegen Familie und so. Das ist auch schon wieder was allein dafür. Ich glaube, charakterlich ist er ein guter, der bei Barca ins Team kommt. Und der war schon viele Jahre und da nehme ich mich selber auch nicht mit aus, so ein bisschen unterm Radar, ein bisschen underrated. Aber was der für eine, also man hat ihn vielleicht dann noch mit seinen Anfangszeiten auch mal bei Arsenal, da hat er schon immer Spiele drin gehabt. Aber wie er sich dann weiterentwickelt hat, zu einer echt festen Torwartgröße, der hinten raus auch noch das Spiel mit dem Ball am Fuß gelernt hat. Also von daher glaube ich passt er dann auch als Ersatz für Ter Stegen ganz gut.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir so eben die Verletzung von Ter Stegen, die jetzt schon eine ganze Weile ja zurückliegt und die jeder mitbekommen hat. Aber finde ich schön, dass wir die auch noch erwähnt haben. Ich meine, das ist ja auch nochmal eine ganz eigene Geschichte mit verschiedensten Dimensionen. Dass es jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt dann eine so schwere Verletzung sein muss. Aber so ist es eben. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Es hat großen Spaß wieder gemacht, zu euren Ligen zu sprechen. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich mache das jetzt wieder kollektiv. Ziehen wir das nicht unnötig in die Länge. Danke, dass ihr die Zeit hattet für den Rasenfunk. Wie immer eine große Freude und ich freue mich, wenn wir dann alle zusammen ins Kino gehen. Das ist doch jetzt hiermit beschlossen, oder? Also danke euch.
Klassenfahrt, juhu.
Sehr gut.
Danke für die Einladung.
Ich danke euch für die, wie immer, sehr gute Vorbereitung und ich danke auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern da draußen, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Dafür, dass ihr diese Folge weiterempfehlt, bewertet, dem Rasenfunk gewogen bleibt und dass ihr den Rasenfunk ermöglicht. Denn ihr wisst ja, alles, was wir hier machen, ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wie funktioniert das, fragt ihr. Das funktioniert nur über euch und über Menschen wie Marie65P, 93, ThomasMD, Yannick, Klaus-Dieter, PdeWollitz, nicht der echte, vermutlich, und Taktikteufel. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub gegangen, denn da erfährt man, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Geht via Paypal, Kreditkarte, Banküberweisung, kleine Beträge, große Beträge, alles ist willkommen und fließt eben in die Gäste, ins Programm der Rasenfunk. Er wird sich weiterentwickeln. Dank euch. Herzlichen Dank dafür, rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub. Bleibt gesund, bis bald, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.